I'm grateful for the chance to speak and
grateful for the accommodation uh to be
able to speak uh remotely actually
um
I'm someone with respiratory uh Health
accommodation related to air pollution
and I'm grateful for Stanford to uphold
the Americans with Disabilities Act
which not many people realize applies to
respiratory conditions so if that's
something you struggle with and you were
unaware of that
um that's a real thing
so today I want to uh really present
some ideas that I'm developing here at
Stanford at cosmex and invite you to
think about these questions and help me
uh work on a review article that I'm
creating on this question of how we
govern uh algorithms especially in
context where they adapt to human
behavior so I'm going to be presenting
and then I'm going to invite you to have
a conversation with each other and with
me in ways that hopefully generate ideas
for your work and also for some of the
research I'm working on here at Stanford
so if you click on that uh link short
URL listed there and leave that open if
you have a computer
um do write down ideas as they occur to
you as we have the conversation today
so this is where I want to start in
2014.
um after someone illegally broke into
multiple celebrity photo accounts uh
people posted non-consensual intimate
imagery to Forums on the social platform
Reddit as people downloaded and reacted
to the photos read its popularity
algorithms promoted them to even more
people and those people kept the cycle
going and even donated money in
appreciation earning Reddit more than a
hundred thousand dollars before the
company banned the content a week later
now if you've not used Reddit before
here's a view of Reddit in September
2014. with the illegal images obscured
if you haven't ever encountered the site
like any uh you know like other sites
like Facebook YouTube Twitter Tick Tock
the system presents a population of
people with content invites reactions
and discussion and incorporates that
information into a ranking of content it
recommends since these algorithms were
first developed in the early 1990s for
music the whole subfield of computer
science and recommender systems uh
reinforcement algorithms now develop and
validates these systems for use in stock
trading map routing predictive policing
Market mechanisms and many other areas
of society
and an article on toxic technocultures
the communications scholar edgen
nasanari describes how non-human
technological agents can shape and are
shaped by human activity during this
really horrific episode a set of
powerful non-human technological agents
including reddit's business model its
corporate policies its popularity
algorithms were driving and being
influenced by large groups of people in
cultures with dehumanizing views of
women encouraged by the many thousands
who viewed and spread the Symmetry
without consent
now at the micro level what does this
cycle look like when Lawrence's images
were shared on Reddit the platform's
visual design showed people previews
enticing headlines and popularity scores
individual users were looking at them
through the interface seeing that they
were popular and uploading and sharing
them with others and these Collective
indicators participated in a wider
culture of misogyny that predates and is
much wider than Reddit
and of course the Reddit ranking
algorithm observed this behavior and
made it even more prominent through the
visual design pouring fuel onto an
already active fire
now in any situation of mutual causality
it's difficult to attribute
responsibility to a single part of the
system and it's hard to know if changing
a single part will change the overall
outcomes imagine for example that you
ban or change the algorithm will that
get rid of misogyny or prevent images
from being circulated in this clay
entirely
and how are you going to cause millions
of humans to behave differently towards
women when many institutions and their
business models actually depend on
dehumanizing women
facing these difficulties a group of 17
social and computer scientists published
an article in pnas last year pointing
out that science does not have access to
a theory-driven empirically verified
body of literature to answer questions
about the effects of algorithms on
society or I would add to the effects of
society on algorithms
and so that's what I'm here to work on
during my year at Stanford Building
Bridges and theory and methods between
computer scientists and social
scientists to predict and influence
feedback between human and algorithm
Behavior
and today I want to explain my research
question in enough detail to enable you
to share ideas and to inform my project
this year and I want to thank those of
you who've already been responding to my
tweets to emails and offered helpful
feedback and references as I put this
together
and I want to start by explaining how
this fits into my broader work and the
work of the lab I lead at Cornell using
a paper that I happen to review I then
want to introduce the two projects for
my year one is this Theory paper and
then another is work on an Empirical
research agenda
so as a computational social scientist I
can't put myself in the same kind of
disciplinary box with an instant view of
how I work as say a psychologist or an
economist I see myself like the sociable
weaver bird of southern Africa which
weaves contributions with others to
create compound nests that support whole
communities over the years I published
papers in a range of scholarly venues
across computer science social
psychology with collaborations in
science and technology studies as well
as law
my ideal research project achieves at
least two out of three things it answers
a pragmatic question faced by
communities it advances Theory and it
also contributes to policy in some way
how does that actually work my approach
to creating knowledge is inspired by
what social psychologists Pelican
chaldini called full cycle research my
version which I call citizen of
community Behavioral Science it often
starts in conversations with communities
about issues that matter to them these
conversations prompt engagement with
Theory we then carry out observations
and Analysis together of the world which
then leads to collaborative field
experiments randomized trials together
with communities which we interpret with
communities to contribute back to Theory
and this is all supported by novel
research infrastructure that makes
fundamental computer contributions to
the computer science of how we design
software for social research
and I do this work alongside the
citizens and Technology Lab at Cornell
and ngo-like research group that
organizes Citizen Community Behavioral
Science on Digital Life
to show you what this looks like in
practice I want to share a study that
really first led me to think about this
human algorithm governance deadline work
in 2016 I was approached by volunteer
moderators of the world news subreddit
community on Reddit a group of over 14
million subscribers who organized to
share Global News the community uses
Reddit but like all subreddit
communities are independent from the
company their international team of over
70 moderators has facilitated
discussions and created their own
policies since 2008.
now here's a story that someone posted
to the world news community in 2017. now
almost everything about these headlines
was wrong the man in this particular
case uh of alleged terrorism was a
Spanish National he had a mental illness
he was not speaking Arabic and
unfortunately the world news Community
receives dozens of Articles like this
every day and some of them become so
popular that reddit's algorithms were
promoting them to even more people
and of course managing that problem was
taking a lot of work
now this community also had a policy
idea something they thought could help
can we encourage readers to question
news from inaccurate sources they asked
they also had some uncertainty what if
their policy solution had an unintended
side effect of causing reddit's
algorithms to promote that news even
further how might a social or computer
scientist think about this question
now Scholars have studied misinformation
by trying to correct it at several
levels looking at how people develop and
change our beliefs
studying the social structures that
shape the spread of information and
people's perceptions of it and online
these perceptions beliefs and social
structures are all interrelated with the
actions of algorithms managing
misinformation requires more than
influencing people it now involves
influencing algorithms
so how have Scholars try to create
knowledge about humans and algorithms
Labs lab and field experiments in human
computer interaction communication
psychology often look at the effect of
computer-generated stimuli on individual
behavior and beliefs and of course
computer scientists sometimes study the
mathematics and the design of the
algorithm code using proof simulations
and more recently even agent-based
models ethnographers in communication
and Science and Technology Studies have
watched people in algorithms interact
and develop new ways to talk about these
interactions and much of this
scholarship not all of it adopts or
critiques a kind of technological
determinism assuming one-way flow is of
influence from software engineers and
training data to software design and
from software then to human behavior
but in my conversation with moderators
of the world news Community I realized
we needed a further kind of knowledge
they wanted to influence the algorithm
now if algorithms can influence human
behavior how might someone actually
influence an algorithm computer
scientists often focus on Direct
influence right the software Engineers
who create it the data standard creators
Define what it's able to know the
training data sets that sometimes steer
its early actions
but adaptive algorithms are also
designed to be indirectly influenced
their function is to observe human
behavior and react accordingly so
influencing adaptive algorithms in some
sense isn't hard they're designed for
that purpose but what's hard is
systematically influencing them and
predicting what will happen next
when the Wilderness Community asked of
encouraging fact checking might make the
Articles trend on platform algorithms
here's what they were worried about
if someone posted inaccurate news and
the community suggested volunteer fact
checking what would happen if people
actually went ahead and in fact checked
the articles but the news aggregator
notice interpret skepticism is
popularity and then promote inaccurate
news
now anthropologies have studied these
intuitions describing them as Folk
theories that often differ from the
underlying mechanisms of an algorithm
selling citizens and Community science
we treat these intuitions as testable
hypotheses
the community was wondering about
something that engineers and behavioral
scientists at the time had studied that
since human behavior influenced
algorithm Behavior attempts to influence
human behavior might also have
Downstream effects on those algorithms
and does a community with no power to
directly change the software code they
wanted to know what kind of power they
might directly exert in this situation
to test this idea I designed software to
respond whenever someone posted a new
tabloid article to the community in the
control group the software made no
suggestions and a treatment group it
suggested fact checking we also had
other interventions and there are more
details to share but today I'm going to
just give you the broad outline
I then observed two outcomes the first
was whether people included links to
further evidence in their comments I
also monitored the monitored the
promotion of articles by the Reddit
algorithm as measured by their rank
position over time
the study found as expected that
encouraging people to fact check did
increase fact checks
um that kind of nudge is not very
surprising the more interesting finding
looked at the downstream effect on the
Reddit algorithm this chart shows the
average treatment effect on algorithm
Behavior at a given moment over time in
the first seven hours after an article
was posted for people who don't do
quantitative research like it's a wiggly
dark orange line is below the horizontal
black line at zero an intervention
reduced how much the algorithm promoted
something over time
across hundreds of discussions articles
that received an encouragement towards
fact checking were demoted in the
rankings by up to 24 ranked positions on
average compared to the control group
and not to move them off the community's
front page now that's good news for the
community
based on this knowledge the community
can make a clear decision about what to
do without having to convince the
company to change their software
so how might this help us answer the
question about governing misinformation
posed by that group of scientists the
community and I showed that people can
influence the behavior of an Adaptive
algorithm in helpful ways without access
to the underlying code they're
systematically coordinated Collective
action and on the longer paper under
review I show how experiments of this
kind can also help us think about why we
see these effects potentially guiding
future interventions
but should the community keep doing this
in the future there's a problem uh
Robert kitchen and many others have
written about the challenge of making
scientific discoveries or any kind of
reusable knowledge about algorithm
behavior these systems are frequently
written by their creators and their
behavior is contingent on changing
surroundings
so can we really say that the findings
of past study will be useful for guiding
future interventions since we did this
red has changed their algorithm multiple
times
will this effect still hold in the
future
I don't know that's that is the moment
the moment I realized that was the
moment I started thinking about this
dilemma of governing algorithms if we
can't make General discoveries about
human and algorithm Behavior what does
that mean for our ability to govern
these systems
I should also mention briefly that field
experiments like this require novel
computational research infrastructures
as our lab develops these studies we
also publish open software and computer
science research about the design and
evaluation of Industry independent
methods to study Digital Life
uh in addition to journal Publications
our work on Research infrastructures has
twice been honored in the field of
design for being some of the best
designs in the world in a given year
so let's talk about this algorithm
governance dilemma this study got me
thinking about the question of whether
the community should adopt their policy
they tested and what kind of science
they might need to make wise decisions
this fall and this year at casmus I'm
working on a review article to try to
summarize this dilemma something I hope
will help motivate computer scientists
and social scientists to work together
on this question so as I talk more about
the broader challenge I would very much
welcome you thinking about writing down
and engaging with the knowledge you have
from your corner of research that might
help illuminate this question
the puzzle of human algorithm feedback
is urgently important in many of the
issues Scholars uh Stanford I know are
working on
just to name some examples of the areas
where this applies in algorithms
oppression Sophia Noble documents how
search engines respond to prejudiced
information supplies and search Behavior
to amplify Prejudice and stereotypes
Scholars like Avril Epps darling have
documented the impact of algorithmic
racism and the mental health of teens
from marginalized groups initiated the
White House incorporate into its mental
health strategy this year
Scholars including Lisa Kimura and
William Frye have theorized how
algorithms contribute to the racial
socialization of white Americans
and Beyond cultural and social issues
related to prejudice and discrimination
we can think of many other contexts
Market mechanisms and behaviors create
algorithm wage discrimination empirical
work that island kaliskin and others
have done adaptive algorithms that
cluster People based on preferences and
behaviors of governments can affect the
lives of people like Wilmer Catalan
Ramirez who is wrongfully incarcerated
partly due to Chicago's predictive
policing algorithm and they also affect
markets at moments like the 2010
flashcraft which allegedly resulted from
the behavior of algorithmic Traders and
which led to the arrest of a British
Trader and a complete ban on the kinds
of algorithms he used
but even as we worry about the risks
Society has also seen beautiful examples
of humans and algorithms that cooperate
to spread generosity grow human
understand it and develop transformative
citizen power there are people who are
alive and healthy today and who live in
Hope of a more just Society thanks to
the benefits of feedback loops between
humans and algorithms that also happen
to be capable of tremendous harm
so the article I'm working on I try to
introduce this problem and puzzle of
generalizable knowledge and why it
matters and this new piece Builds on a
review article I wrote with Lucas Wright
earlier this year about social justice
and algorithm governance that we
published with the social science
research Council
this dilemma is about the consequences
for democracy of learning whether a
theory driven governance of algorithms
is possible or not
and that is a conversation that goes
back hundreds of years this is a picture
from Robert Boyle's new experiments the
19 1606 which established the dream that
scientists seek repeatable knowledge
developing developing testable
hypotheses validated through
reproduction and demonstration
and this kind of generalizable knowledge
if it could be obtained would also be
pragmatically valuable if we could
describe predict and reliably change the
behavior of humans and algorithms we
might be able to govern our complex
World more effectively
in one view as I mentioned before maybe
algorithm behavior isn't a science if
general knowledge is unattainable then
general policies might be impossible
but maybe that's a good thing in 2019
Central Nathan argued that algorithm
Behavior has more easily changed than
human behavior quote biased algorithms
are easier to fix than biased people you
might spend a decade like Sundale
failing to resolve a discrimination
problem in human institutions or you can
delegate power to a computer reprogram
it to stop engaging in discrimination if
Central is right the moment you change
the algorithm pass knowledge about Its
Behavior becomes Obsolete and you have a
fresh start on getting things right so
long as algorithm creators do the right
thing
but if some people believe that human
behavior is predictable and algorithm
behavior is not some computer scientists
who study adaptive algorithms have
another view that algorithm behavior is
predictable but humans are not consider
Engineers interested in a predictable
note or a particular notion of fairness
these Engineers might create or train a
system to be initially fair that could
become unfair over time or it might move
towards a more fair State something that
computer scientists are not easily able
to predict because both human and system
Behavior are Dynamic over time as
Michael extract and a number of others
have
argued in their monograph on fairness
and discrimination in information access
systems
companies agree they can't predict the
behavior of their algorithms because
humans are unpredictable last year meta
head of policy Nick Clegg argued that
the company has less power to influence
their own algorithms than Regulators
think
in a post about feedback loops Clegg
suggests that since Facebook's
algorithms are effectively held hostage
to the unpredictable actions of Facebook
users affected governments does not rely
on necessarily on holding Facebook's
algorithms accountable but instead
requires more surveillance and
regulation of human behavior basically
to protect Facebook's algorithms from
the public that's one reason the company
invests over half a billion dollars a
year in content moderation surveilling
the digital behaviors of billions of
people and using often unreliable
enforcement algorithms
to make instantaneous decisions about
what behaviors to allow or not
I don't have time today to speak about
my lab's work on automated law
enforcement but happy to meet up with
folks and talk more about that work
later
so if you haven't seen one of my talks
before then I want you to take a moment
to guess what this machine does
because monitoring humans isn't the only
option in a world where generalizable
knowledge is hard to obtain
this is actually one of my favorite
Machines of all time
I'll give you another second to make if
we were in the room I'd ask for guesses
um
so this is actually a sock testing
machine used in the 1930s by Consumer
Reports a memory organization that does
testing journalism and advocacy for
Consumer Protection this machine applies
consistent amounts of friction to a
large number of socks to find out which
ones are the most durable it's amazing
now let's ask ourselves is knowledge
about human sock interaction repeatable
if I test a random sample of socks on
this machine will I be able to predict
the reliability of future stocks or will
I have to test every new kind of sock on
the market to give you assurances about
sock reliability in a way Consumer
Reports was founded to address the
limitations of general knowledge in the
world of consumer protection
through the creation of
sock accountability Technologies but
it's not transparency and accountability
Technologies let me know if you want to
start a new subfield of computer science
dedicated to the study of socks
um so in the journal article I'm working
on I want to position this broader
question in relation to two ideas about
the role of Science in policy that I
hope you all will help me theorize
better you know like all binaries like
the world is more complicated than this
but I hope it offers like two polls uh
along some Spectrum or other structure
that we'll need to cover in systems
effectively
so on my hand if it's possible to derive
general principles then algorithm policy
would look something like what I imagine
economists think Economic Policy should
look like right we build policies around
general principles and update those
policies from time to time as new more
accurate theories arise
but if prior knowledge is invalidating
every time companies make a change or
each time an algorithm encounters
unexpected unexpected circumstances we
need to govern algorithms an
unprecedented speed in Fidelity we need
tests and standards infrastructures for
continuous monitoring and we'll have to
guess intervention outcomes or evaluate
them rapidly as crises are unfolded
in the meantime we may have to ban
certain kinds of algorithms or if the
history of consumer protection is any a
guide debate the acceptable losses from
continuing to use profitable systems
that we know cause terrible and
irreversible Harms
so as a paper this this project on the
urban governance dilemma will connect
the open question of human algorithm
Behavior with the kinds of governance
regimes that are anti-sterious to we'll
also discuss the methods and systems we
need to create to learn the answers
computers and I want to go through some
of the methods that people are thinking
about and that I've seen uh from
research across multiple fields that I
think offers some hope and promise for
example computer scientists are
investigating whether it's possible to
simulate or model the conditions the
algorithms will face in the future
before putting them into the world a
debate that could be better informed by
historical arguments in the social
sciences about cybernetics complexity
Theory an agent-based modeling
some social scientists have conducted
longitudinal panel studies to observe
this mutual causality and one example is
a project I'm on The Advisory Board of
uh NSF Grant at Northeastern University
to create an observatory for online
human and platform Behavior that's
developing this kind of research
another exciting idea is to observe
populations of algorithms to see if very
different adaptive algorithms
nonetheless behave similar similarly as
researchers have found to be the case
with xenophobic search engine results in
wage discrimination and market pricing
algorithms there's a contribution to be
made from organizational behavior as
well I think of the work by Robin Kaplan
and Dana Boyd about how business models
Drive organizations to create certain
kinds of algorithms by creating putting
balance on what those algorithms can do
and how they can perform
a third idea is actually to study
populations of contacts
um as Hagar and Shah have done in a new
paper just in the last few weeks the
studies the same algorithm as it adapted
to multiple contexts cat lab has also
published research about software to
support large-scale citizen science
studies for similar purposes
but many governance questions are also
about causation what can we do not just
to explain but also to prevent and
respond to problems as they arrive we
have very few lab or field experiments
that look at human algorithm feedback
partly because these experiments are so
challenging to design
in addition to the study I mentioned uh
earlier and a few more in prep William
Brady at the Crockett lab has combined
simulations with lab experiments to ask
similar question in a more controlled
environment
I should also note that especially when
we start talking about field experiments
and the challenges of testing something
in the world versus simulation uh
this question about research methods
also overlaps with the ethics of
proliferation when should we test things
in the lab when do we test them in the
field when is it right to to you know
consider the behavior of a system under
those different
conditions these are questions that have
been widely debated in ecology and
epidemiology
and of course all of these methods have
politics the algorithm governance the
limit is also a dilemma relating to
power and expertise in democracies
and here's where this project connects
back to the history of science as Chapin
and Shaffer argue in Leviathan in the
air pump the very idea of generalizable
knowledge depends on the instruments we
use to ask scientific questions as well
as the politics of science the authors
show how Boyle's idea of the experiment
and the laboratory draw boundaries
around who gets to ask questions who get
to learn the answers and who has to live
with the consequences issues that we
think deeply about as cat lab as we try
to broaden who creates science uh and
who science serves
whether we find generalizable knowledge
or have to rely on situated knowledge
based on continuous monitoring Society
still has decisions to make about the
politics of the instruments we create to
understand and govern algorithms
should we rely on companies to Monitor
and enforce policies on humans at scale
should we create infrastructures like
the sock tester to evaluate algorithms
at scale how do we do that in ways that
protect people while preserving civil
liberties
in the case of scientific governance do
we rely on Behavioral Science teams
inside companies to carry out millions
of secret experiments and hope they do
the right thing can we build an
independent research ecosystem that
enables the public to answer these
questions independently from industry
with standards of ethics and consent the
questions of how to engineer these
scientific instruments and what kind of
knowledge we can produce about human and
algorithm Behavior are absolutely
political questions
and that's what I'm working on
describing in this review article to
review the state of knowledge and
potential directions for scientific
inquiry in ways that incorporate the
political and ethical considerations
that are ultimately at the heart of why
we do this science in the first place
so I very very much welcome uh questions
critiques and suggestion of literature I
want this work to reach a broad audience
of Scholars across multiple disciplines
um and I also know that
um uh creating any work that people see
as reflecting you know the state of
knowledge and also uh creating
compelling and exciting call for new
research is always an interesting dance
so uh any questions doubts ideas hopes
and enthusiasms are welcome
so I want to end with a few comments
about the Empirical research agenda I'm
working on myself and for my own
research lab
at cat lab ideas start when we gather
with affected communities from digital
networks like those on Reddit to
placement Place based communities in New
York City to participants in the global
Wikimedia movement pictured here this
particular participatory in ethnographic
work is an important starting point for
our research designs and whenever I
collaborate with someone it usually
starts by inviting those scientific
collaborators to meet with communities
to hear from them about the things they
care about
another source of collaborators is an
organization I have recently co-founded
that just launched about three weeks ago
the Coalition for independent technology
research already has over 100 members
across journalism so the society and
Academia
and it's coordinating broad diverse
collaboration among industry independent
groups that study technology and society
and I would invite you to join or or ask
me about the coalition
here are some of the studies we're
working on in one study in prep we did
observational research with Community to
notice that conversations promoted by
algorithms on Reddit receive thousands
of more comments on average and that
those conversations also experience
higher rates of online harassment based
on their finding we developed an
experiment to monitor algorithms predict
harassment and intervene in advance when
we expected higher rates of harassment
I'm really excited to be analyzing the
results of that soon
and in collaboration with William Frye
we're working with communities of color
who identify attention whirlpools or
what we're starting to call savior
swarms parts of the Social Web that
algorithms sent people when news about
marginalized communities is trending
online William fry has observed that in
the aftermath of uh police murdering
unarmed black people in this country
white internet users will flock to Black
digital spaces looking for some contest
where they can talk about issues of race
largely because
white Americans don't have many spaces
for that kind of discussion but we're
interested to understand what role
algorithms play in what racial
socialization and what kinds of
interventions can direct that attention
in productive directions
another idea has a project has to do
with the idea of algorithmic reparations
that has been pioneered by April
Williams every year media publishers
alter their algorithms to promote
content from marginalized groups during
special months like black history among
Hispanic Heritage Month women's History
Month Jennifer archione cat lab has
observed that these are like exogenous
shocks to the design of algorithms where
a whole population of systems are
altered to carry out you know with the
goal of carrying out certain kinds of
behavior and so we're working on a
project to study these populations of
algorithms at moments when companies
intervene uh to alter how they behave
so more broadly in the Empirical
research agenda I'm assembling uh I'm
going to be focusing on the research
infrastructures needed to answer the
kinds of questions in addition to
expanding our existing field experiment
software and actually making it
available to a broader group of
scientific collaborators which you
should reach out if you're interested to
do field experiments like this because
we're starting to build a community of
practice to use our systems in addition
to that work we're going to be
developing systems for adaptive
experimentation on algorithm Behavior or
research system monitors the behavior of
automated system in real time and adjust
the details of the study accordingly a
technique inspired by methods in ecology
also considering software to guide
collaborative hypothesis generation with
communities inspired by work being done
by the pandate on crowdsourcing
hypotheses and in the area I'm kind of
at least sure about but I'm thinking a
lot more about this here I've been
thinking a lot about bridging between
models in the field finding ways to
bring
simulations and field experimentation
together making them more empirically
grounded and informed by affected
communities that's probably the most
but out there still thinking area so I
especially excited to brainstorm about
that
all of this will of course be
underpinned by our continued work on
Research ethics and privacy for citizen
Behavioral Science including a report
cat lab is writing on the topic this
year for Consortium of several large
us-based scientific funders
you know
so to wrap up I want to just point out
human algorithm Behavior it's a hard
problem for Science and policy and no
single scientist will be able to develop
a universal solution
so why focus on the science and politics
of research methods as I and Catholic
have done
in the early days of the audio industry
nearly a million people had died in car
crashes alone in the U.S Alone by 1950.
yet policies blamed drivers instead of
companies focusing on speed limit
enforcement rather than the design of
injury prevention
this is Hugh de Haven a researcher at
Cornell who designed some of the first
reliable car safety test methods for
decades people said that car safety was
too complicated to test you have all of
these Dynamics going on at the moment of
a crash
to Haven proved them wrong showing that
you could predict human injuries by
measuring what happened to a test device
like the one on the left in a stage
crash
this work on test methods paved away for
citizen advocacy government regulation
and changes within the Auto industry for
car safety and in the subsequent decades
it saved millions of lives
today's tech company is in the tech
industry are in a similar position to
the 1950s Auto industry we know these
technologies have dangers
but we can't fully create the knowledge
to make them safer if social scientists
and computer scientists can even
partially resolve that algorithm
governance dilemma we can do a lot of
good for society
so that's the end of my formal
comments and hopefully the beginning of
a conversation and before
you pose questions here's what I'd like
you to do
um take
three minutes if you're if you're in if
you're in the room with uh with others
take three minutes and talk to the
person next to you uh and think about
a question or an idea that relates to
your research that intersects with this
broader challenge of using science to
govern algorithms and human algorithm
behavior and and use that as a
springboard for something that you could
write in the document or that you could
ask uh or pose and share in the session
and for as a reminder here's the URL for
accessing the shared document because
even if we don't get to all the
questions and comments uh add your name
and then I can follow up and I know the
reference or the idea or the link that
you share and if you're you know joining
us remotely maybe take a moment to think
by yourself uh and and do the same so
I'm going to turn on a timer and then we
can call on folks and go from there for
for questions and discussion
okay I'm starting the timer now
okay we are at three minutes
so I I will let
the folks in the room uh apply the
excellent facilitation skills to queue
up questions comments and participation
I've never had my facilitation skills
described as excellent before but I will
do my best okay so folks
um if you uh are interested in engaging
regardless of whether you wrote
something in the document please use the
raise hand tool on Zoom we will unmute
you and we'll have a discussion so
please go ahead and start clicking on
raised raise hand not everyone sort of
signed their their comment in the
document uh but uh oh I see uh you uh
put your hand up so you want to take us
take us off kick us off uh I'm I'm only
moderately
good at facilitation apparently so go
for it
yeah absolutely
um I hope my my mic is okay maybe
awesome
um so I I wrote this in the document as
well but I'll read it out here so
building off of the idea that we have of
the crash test dummy in the car accident
um that's some you know something that
stands in for human beings uh that we
can then measure impacts on and apply
those those impacts to human beings I
was thinking about some kind of I don't
know a crash test form or crash test
platform or website that these big
companies might use to test out their
algorithms changes they make moderation
pipelines before they actually release
them onto their actual platforms
um I I I'm not sure if there's something
like this in practice already from my
understanding a b testing actually in
the uh you know in sort of the
production environment in the real world
is the most common way that companies
try things like introducing new
moderation tools or introducing new
tools for adding context to articles or
things like that
um but obviously that can sort of cause
an issue if they make changes that have
the opposite effect and actually amplify
things like misinformation hate speech
impersonation maybe to give an example
from Twitter so I was just curious if
there's any work being done in sort of
developing some kind of
practical test space for for that sort
of thing
yeah I love that question uh a few
thoughts oh it's so generative we could
have a whole whole session just on that
um
you know that the self-driving car world
has done some of this work to create
simulated environments to see how
systems behave under those circumstances
also there's some work being done by
Ellen nutrini at Princeton and I'm sure
a number of others uh to some of the
conceptual informal work uh to Define
how simulations might be helpful in some
of those contexts
um
one of the one of the challenges is that
your uh you know ability to to manage
that safety then is only as good as your
simulation
um and there's a risk of your client
relying too much on it one the other
thing I'll observe is that uh and
there's a whole literature on
engine-based models and simulation and
their external validity that has arisen
in a number of other social science
health and I'm really interested to do
more reading on particularly in
economics
um one thing I will note is that uh
people sometimes
uh think of like what people sometimes
bring a deterministic Viewpoint to the
ethics of considering these Technologies
right if the concern is that if you
introduce the technology then it will
unleash new kinds of hatred or harm then
you might have really good reason to
hold back and do as much as you can to
predict and prevent problems uh
but also sometimes there are certain
problems that only occur when the
ingredients fit together right the in
context uh the system will you know gets
used by a certain set of actors and so
as much as you try to Red Team something
or simulate or anticipate problems
that is often where experimentation can
be incredibly valuable and rather than
thinking of experimentation as a means
to
um
evaluate some like one mode is where you
use experimentation to evaluate
something on a limited basis with a
constrained number of people that you've
calculated with you know power analyzes
and sample size estimation and that has
a long it's a valuable ethical
standpoint in its own right I think
there's also a scope for
um doing things that speed up the pace
at which we learn how to manage things
that are already in the world and our
active harms and that's one of the
reasons why I'm more and more interested
in adopting adaptive experimentation
techniques so that when something
horrible starts to happen you have a
chance to rapidly learn how to manage it
um even if you go into the situation not
knowing as much about what to do but I
think this is you've identified one of
the key questions and particularly the
the way that it interacts with the the
debates about proliferation and when
it's right to put a technology into the
world even even if the goal is to learn
uh the effectiveness of interventions
thanks so much
so we can hear from other people it's
just a good question
uh a reminder for folks please raise
your hand uh there are several
possibilities in the document
I don't know if you're actually capable
of unmuting without getting a huge audio
Loop so chat at me if you want me to to
proxy you
um
so
uh I wrote two things in the document
and they thought I don't know if there's
one or the other that seems more
interesting to you uh one's around
sort of metaphors of between human
behavior and algorithmic Behavior Uh and
the other is sort of the tension between
normative values and emergent Behavior
should we pick a topic
um
yeah talk to me about the second one
because I'm not sure I fully understand
it and that makes it interesting yeah so
um
normally when we talk about sort of
governance we look at you know where we
we think about where are the points of
intervention right we can say when you
sell some bubble gum you must add the
following text or something like this
um
the you wouldn't trade-off that sort of
was coursing through your talk from my
in from my taking you know exemplified
by the Nick Clegg article but also you
know these these Loops these sort of
causal diagram Loops that that were
coming up was that a lot of these
outcomes are emergent behaviors right so
they were not designed to do the
algorithm they were not designed into
the sort of human behavior but they're
sort of these uh this the result of the
combination
and
in contrast when we talk about
what we ought to govern or regulate and
so on we often take a much a far more
normative or almost deontological point
of view where like we do not want you
know no algorithm should do this it
shouldn't push teen girls on Instagram
toward bad body Images uh it should not
be amplifying misinformation uh it
should not be facilitating harassment
right so there's these fairly uh kind of
the thing that we're unhappy with is the
emergent outcome but you can't just
directly legislate an emergent outcome I
mean you could I suppose you could say
if this or if this emergent outcome
arises you're going to get sued by the
government or something but it's harder
because it's sort of because of the fact
that it's emergent right it's coming up
from all these different positions
simultaneously so I so I'm just I was
just kind of thinking through as you
were talking
where there might be analogies in other
walks of life that are non-technological
where there's this sort of emergent
outcome where human behavior doesn't
intentionally you know at scale try to
create this but it does and where do we
intervene I'm thinking of like the FED
as one place where this happens but it's
I don't know I want to try to avoid sort
of Market metaphors and I'm trying to
think of other spaces where there's this
uh this tightrope we're walking between
sort of like these normative outcomes we
care about but like the the thing that
we're actually trying to control is a
collective emergent thing I'm just
looking for other examples of that in
non-tech spaces
yeah that's such a such an important
observation Michael and it gives me an
opportunity to draw on my Humanities
training so so in some ways this goes
back to Thomas Aquinas
um and and some of the arguments about
what how we think about like what
constitutes moral conduct in the summer
theological to like the loss a few
centuries of Western philosophy
um basically you know he's writing about
for example violence right do do you
consider the like ending of another
person's life
to be the problem or the like sinking
the knife in to be the thing you care
about right uh and you know this is
actually some something that uh
artificial intelligence researchers
study when they do all of these trolley
problems right to what degree is it the
action that we care about uh and how
many
how many
steps far removed from the outcome
someone is versus the outcome uh and
I think for the you're right that these
are emergent behaviors and and when we
think about regulation of like
individuals we do often think about like
you can or cannot take x or y action but
ultimately what
governments care about are outcomes and
and in theory the social sciences uh
have enabled governance governments to
be able to think about and societies to
be thinking about to think about
different kinds of governments that
focuses on outcomes rather than means
right and surrounding needs and you know
for an example would be education right
where we care about the outcomes on
learning right and there are many many
interventions and we hopefully engage in
a uh like an endless search for the most
effective interventions to improve
learning similarly public health is
another greater knowledge Jonathan
zitrin has written about this I've
written a number of Articles
um where you know the purpose of Public
Health is to you know promote
flourishing life and healthy uh you know
well-being and there are any number of
interventions right during the pandemic
you mask distance you take vaccines
um and the the goal right is policies
that support like Evolution and
interventions towards those broader Norm
ends we care about uh ecology is also
another area which I found really
inspiring because the environment is one
area where we have sometimes competing
actors that are generating emergent
outcomes and and
um one great example would be the work
of Eleanor Austin where you know just in
her work as a political scientist
described uh situations where you have
Community groups uh
Fisheries
regulators
Industries who share like who are in
some cases polluting into waterways and
they're all optimizing for different
things and uh you know she was arguing
for the kinds of evidence making that
are needed to promote overall stability
in an ecosystem in a context where
multiple groups have have competing uh
goals and and her work has really
inspired my thinking about citizen
science where citizen Sciences has for a
long time played an important role in in
moderating the excesses of these
emergent
behaviors in Environmental Management so
I think there are some really powerful
analogies and I think for this uh for
this piece I think some of the most
helpful ones are going to come from
probably a combination of Public Health
epidemiology as well as uh ecological
management where there's been a lot of
empirical work over the years you know
of course alongside all of the market uh
Market related work that folks have done
but yeah I think the work that I do is
particularly focused on ends and I think
the challenge we have with current
regulations is that they're very focused
on means right you know privacy
regulation which is about
data and what you do with it when
ultimately what people are Regulators
care about is something very different
from from data the final thing I'll say
is that um
this is where the courts have an
important role to play like the division
of tort law has has often been much more
focused on ants than means and this is
why we see Attorneys General and
strategic litigators taking up uh and
and seeking uh the kind of evidence they
can anchor uh responsibility in the
outcomes for people and societies rather
than debating like what happened you
know at the desk of a particular
software engineer or set of decision
makers at a company on that given day
all right more conversation to come
excellent yes more to come
um there's lots of other interesting
stuff to chat about in the in the
document ranging from you know sort of
what's the what's the attack model the
the analogy of the sock machine they
knew what uh you know what what the
danger was can social science give us
enough that you know we can sort of now
expect that everyone should be able to
protect against the following things
um uh questions around how this all
comes together with capitalism uh and
and are the critiques the same or
difference uh things around
recommendation algorithms and so on uh
we're virtually out of time so we're
gonna have to talk about that offline uh
but I look forward to the conversation
and I want to thank May again Nathan
again for joining us uh from Cornell and
again he'll be around if you want to
chat with him
yeah I sorry I took so much time
answering questions it's such good good
comments and I like look out for the
opportunity to hang out over lunch or
otherwise I'm really excited to meet
folks learn from you see if there are
ways that I can offer feedback and ideas
for your own research and uh and connect
and what's the best way for people to
find you if they want to reach out
so the easiest way
um I'll share it on my screen again it's
my email address
nathan.matias
cornell.edu
and I'm also uh Nate Matthias at
social.coop on Mastodon all right
thanks again Nathan and I think we'll
end it here
have an enjoyable rest of your Friday